[Musica]
[Applauso]
adelina e una signora benestante di 80
anni ha vissuto una bellissima vita
finora
ma ora è sola perché vedova e senza
figli
in un grande appartamento nel centro di
una città italiana
è aiutata nei lavori domestici da una
colf
tutti i giorni scena il supermercato
sotto casa per fare due parole con le
cassiere gentili
cosa ci dice tutto questo
uno che ha difficoltà ad avere relazioni
interpersonali
e poi che nel caso di un problema di
salute significativo per esempio la
rottura di una gamba
il primo provvedimento a cui si
ricorrerà massara l'ospedalizzazione che
significa la perdita dell'autonomia e un
difficile ritorno a casa
pensate che tutto ciò non solo ha un
impatto sulla salute sullo stato d'animo
di adelina ma anche sui costi del
welfare sanitario
avete idea di quanto costi una lunga
ospedalizzazione al sistema sanitario
nazionale
i dati del ministero della salute
riferiti al 2019
ci dicono che i ricoveri in
riabilitazione
ammontano a circa 2 miliardi di euro
la nostra delina e lì in questa
casistica
come tante altre persone che non possono
stare a casa loro perché non hanno
nessuno che si prenda cura di loro
quanta deli ne conoscete voi perché
fanno parte della vostra famiglia o
delle vostre conoscenze
bene
la presa in carico di adelina è comunque
possibile perché il sistema del welfare
è stato così concepito è un sistema è
stata una conquista meravigliosa del
novecento creata per garantire a tutti
istituzioni e servizi
universale pagate dallo stato con
l'obiettivo di garantire la salute
l'educazione e via dicendo
nel frattempo ci sono stati due eventi
invecchiamento demografico la crisi
economica del welfare la difficoltà a
mantenere i costi
e poi
e poi c'è stato il covip che ha
letteralmente
sconquassato le nostre vite
la casa è tornata al centro di tutto
telelavoro
didattica distanza
solitudine
sovraffollamento una casa spesso
inadeguata a rispondere alle nuove
esigenze
e qui
bisogna fare proprio bisogna ripensare
al nostro modo di vivere all'interno
delle abitazioni
qui interviene il cohousing
che cos'è il co housing
è un termine di origine anglosassone che
si può tradurre sostanzialmente come
abitare collaborativo
e una comunità intenzionale in cui più
famiglie
decidono di andare abitare vicini per
collaborare fra loro
famiglie che sono
diversissime per tipo per età
per interessi culturali
per provenienza sociale che hanno un
appartamento più o meno grande e al e
tanti spazi comuni
spazi che sono molto più ampie di quelli
presenti nei condomini tradizionali che
non si riducono a un pianerottolo o a un
androne
spazi che sono
salotti con televisioni
librerie grandi cucine
orti giardini aree giochi per bimbi
lavanderie
spazi di tutti che favoriscono
l'interazione e dunque la relazione
perché cohousing è un modello abitativo
che mette al centro la relazione fra le
persone
ed è frutto
di un lungo percorso in cui ognuno è
tenuto
a dare il suo contributo in prima
persona per arrivare a definirne tutti
gli aspetti
condividere scelte
beni e servizi
rafforza il gruppo
oltre a produrre notevoli vantaggi
economici
ci sono vari varie forme di abitare
collaborativa
che si basano su un livello diverso di
condivisione sì certo
abbiamo il cohousing ma non solo ci sono
le coabitazioni solidali gli ecovillaggi
i condomini solidali
le cooperative di abitanti
il cohousing
nasce in nord europa negli anni 70
ed è un'evoluzione possiamo dire delle
case collettive svedesi degli anni
cinquanta è lecito perché sono state un
esempio
importantissimo perché hanno aiutato le
donne che si affacciavano in maniera
massiccia nel mondo del lavoro a
conciliare il lavoro con la cura della
famiglia
grazie attraverso degli spazi comuni e
la condivisione di servizi
in italia arriva negli anni 2000
e si sviluppa specialmente in piemonte
emilia romagna lombardia e toscana
i numeri sono ancora bassi in italia non
sono alti come il nord europa
diciamo una quarantina
perché così pochi perché nascono da
iniziative private coraggiose
di cittadini che si mettono insieme e
acquistano un co housing perché non c'è
nessuno lo stato in primis che supporta
questi modelli abitativi come avviene
invece in altri paesi europei dove si
trova anche il co housing in affitto
inoltre manca una legge
che renda questi
modelli residenziali un soggetto
giuridico a tutti gli effetti ne
faciliti la realizzazione
dando la possibilità ad esempio di
chiedere un prestito bancario senza
dover costituire una cooperativa
oppure
pagare la tassa rifiuti senza essere
considerati un albergo perché si succede
anche questo
per fortuna nel
2020 è stata depositata in parlamento
una proposta di legge
e noi come rete italiana quasi ne
abitare collaborativo insieme ad altre
associazioni attive sul territorio
nazionale ci stiamo battendo per fare
andare avanti e riuscire a portare a
compimento questa legge
le caratteristiche del cohousing sono la
fiducia all'aiuto reciproco e la
condivisione di valori questo
costituisce quelli capitale sociale che
ha un impatto positivo sul territorio
e fare le cose insieme dayco abitanti
non rimane chiuso fra le mura di casa
ma conta già l'esterno
può essere dunque veramente una
strategia di rigenerazione urbana lo
scherzo
e vi faccio un esempio
torinese
nel 2009
un co housing che si chiama
che si chiama numero zero ha deciso di
insediarsi in un quartiere
multietnico
considerato problematico perché per anni
meta di una massiccia immigrazione prima
del sud italia con il boom economico con
la fiat e poi da paesi extraeuropei
qui
i cos'era hanno iniziato a conoscere i
loro vicini di quartiere attraverso
la partecipazione all organizzazione ad
eventi locali
fino a costituire nel 2020 una
fondazione di comunità che raduna queste
soggetti attivi che vogliono migliorare
il loro quartiere
si può dire che grazie anche al numero
zero oggi quartiere un posto più
vivibile
ma torniamo alla nostra delina
ora la vita in un co housing al piano
terra ed al suo alloggio può ammirare le
sue bellissime rose di fianco ci sta ed
un single con due gatti il piano di
sopra abitano una famiglia con due figli
di 4 e 7 anni
e una coppia senza figli di viaggiatori
compulsivi
in mansarda ci stanno tre studenti
universitari
bene ecco che qui noi abbiamo la
possibilità di costruire dei rapporti di
solidarietà e aiuto reciproco differenti
quando l'anno scorso
adelina sia ammalata non è stata portata
all'ospedale è rimasta a casa
per fortuna che c'era sonia che fa la
volontaria alla croce rossa e poteva
farle un'iniezione tutte le sere
ora dell'ina che sta meglio invito i
bambini a leggere dei libri di favole
quando la loro mamma fa tardi al lavoro
d'estate adelina sta casa perché il
posto dove sta meglio in assoluto
niente più valigie o spostamenti
faticosi
garantisce così una presenza costante
innaffia i fiori di chi è in vacanza
da da mangiare ai gatti di elio quando
non c'è
chi sera però con chi non è partito si
fa un aperitivo tutti insieme giù in
cortile
perché sì quasi e anche questo
convivialità
e anche qualche regola
adelina si sente utile e accudita
dall'affetto di tutti
aiuta ed aiutata
bello no
anch'io dopo tanti anni di studio scelto
di abitare in un po a faust in fuori
torino
mi ha seguito mio marito
diciamo po riluttante per usare un
eufemismo
siamo una
comunità o un gruppo chiamiamoci o
vicini di casa
molto molto diverso veramente
abbiamo anche diverse capacità
economiche ma per aiutare chi non aveva
la possibilità di comprare perché non
riusciva ad accedere a un mutuo abbiamo
costituito una cooperativa
così ci siamo stati tutti
è difficile mettere così tanto in comune
è difficile prendere decisioni tutti
insieme
allineare i propri sogni o rispettare i
bisogni degli altri
la risposta è che bisogna imparare ad
ascoltare
bisogna essere aperti
bisogna essere flessibili
bisogna lavorare sui propri pregiudizi
ancora no
bisogna imparare a lasciar andare le
proprie idee anche se siamo convinte
convinti che sia le migliori in assoluto
che usiamo
perché queste non sono quelle
abbracciate dal gruppo
è facile
no
ne vale la pena
sì sempre